de nombreux secteurs vont se mobiliser
ce jeudi 23 mars contre la réforme des
retraites malgré l'adoption du texte
avec le 49-3 et le rejet de deux motions
de censure et les Yvelines seront une
nouvelle fois impactées dans les
transports la RATP s'attend un trafic
perturbé sur les RER et recommandent aux
usagers de télétravailler il faudra
s'armer de patience sur les quais un RER
A sur deux circuits ce jeudi et
l'interconnexion sera maintenue à
Nanterre Préfecture pour le RER B
comptait intrins sur deux
l'interconnexion gare du Nord et
maintenu pour le RER C compté deux
trains sur 3 le trafic sera également
perturbé sur les trains de la région
parisienne il y aura trois trains sur 4
sur la ligne N il y aura deux trains sur
3 sur la ligne J et l comptez deux
trains sur 3 pour la ligne U pour les
bus le trafic devrait être quasi normal
dans les Yvelines du côté de
l'enseignement des perturbations sont
attendues dans les écoles les collèges
et les lycées mais aussi dans les
accueils périscolaires et les services
de cantine